[Music]
that theme music can mean only one thing
this is the PR betting show presented by
the Caesars Palace sports book upsets
underachievers and a tie
well wild week one is in the books and
your week to preview starts right now
[Music]
welcome back to the bee our bedding show
alongside our bedding insider the lovely
and talented Kelly Stewart I'm cabby
Richards you know Kelly when I was a kid
there were a few monsters that filled my
nightmares
there was Freddy Krueger the evil t1000
from terminator and Pennywise the clown
from it like I'm not even going to see
the sequel and I don't think I'm alone
Oh
cabbie a lot of fan bases had nightmares
after week one most notably those in
Miami by the way the Dolphins current
odds to win the Superbowl two thousand
to one Wow seen a long shot like that
since McLovin got a fake ID league 11
the he's a he's a national treasure and
so is the NFL so as we look to our
marquee matchups of the week one number
that sticks out is that Patriots and
dolphins spread
Miami is an 18 and a half point under
Sun real life it's real life it was even
as high as nineteen at one point Gaby
that's crazy this is crazy because they
look a headline that we saw here in
Vegas was Pat's minus 11 okay we're
gonna learn a theme this week and it's
called overreaction and that is exactly
what everyone lamed the lumber here with
the Pats is doing
don't forget the Pats one in five
straight up and against the spread their
last six years in Miami you have Brian
Flores who's a former Bill Belichick
assistant cab he asked me early in the
week but doesn't Bill Belichick run it
up on his assistants nose no not unless
her name Bill O'Brien and since 2015
week two home dogs who lost their first
game eighteen and six against the spread
cabbie I gotta go with the fins here
wait wait when you say home dog where's
a home dog a home underdog
okay so the Miami Dolphins will likely
be home underdogs fighting for the rest
of the season most likely yes okay so
now it's time for the NFC Championship
rematch from last year this year the
Saints fly to the LA Coliseum to play
the LA Rams and they are one and a half
point underdogs and the fan base is
still
kaby baby I mean sure they should be
stilling heated but guys it's a little
bit built into the line here I
understand
revenge is a huge motivating factor but
we got to pump the brakes just a little
bit it's been nine months nor was i
impressed by the Saints week one sure
you can make a case that the ramps could
have lost the Panthers as well if I have
to choose I'm gonna fade the Saints here
who were one in ten against a spread in
the first two weeks of the lastik
seasons cabbie I'm gonna roll at the
ramps okay well I'm sorry well what
question where does it mean to fade the
Saints it means I'm gonna bet against
them you're bidding against your brain
gets drew brees who has like seven
thousand career comebacks on his record
on the road against Jared Goff Todd
Gurley the wrong dog both teams have
their stars okay is remember betting
numbers not teams okay so those stars
let's move let's transition to another
Coliseum which will feature another star
the current Madden 20 cover athlete and
rating MVP patches mahomes and his
Kansas City Chiefs
they are seven-point favorites and shout
out to John Boone and his Raiders their
one and O in the season are you betting
the Raiders to go to - no this rod
chewin on was a stretch maybe 200
against the spread okay now you
mentioned my Holmes is the 100% I'm not
sold that he is we saw that ankle with a
lot of tape in Jacksonville sure Kansas
City fans
you're gonna remind me Kansas City eight
and ones sure enough the last nine times
I've played the Raiders this is just too
many points theme number two of the show
divisional home dogs since 2007 week two
divisional home dogs 15 and four get to
spread jogger and moves to 2a no against
to spread the season okay wait a second
you're bidding against Patrick no home
remember last week that guy threw for
211 yards in the first 13 minutes
minutes Kelly and you're going against
moans yes cuz they're on the road for a
second week in a row I gotta take the
points here with the Raiders oh okay hey
listen you're the expert and I'm the
novice all right let's go to the Sunday
Night Football game this is the
Philadelphia Eagles were preseason
Superbowl favorites and they're MVP
caliber quarterback Carson Wentz who I'm
starting on my fantasy team
there are what are the half point
favorites is it going to be a big
fantasy day for me in Carson Wentz
here's my little PSA for the show no
sports bettor cares about your fantasy
team including me and I have Carson
Wentz on my fantasy team I series I care
about my beds guys do not overact eek
one yes the Eagles look good in that
second half versus the Redskins and yes
the Falcons look terrible at the Vikings
but asked Abby mentioned this is a
Sunday night game and we are catching
points with the home team it's one of my
favorite betting things primetime home
dogs Raiders cash on Monday night as
prime time home dogs looking to make it
to a know this week with the Falcons now
this sentence hasn't been said in in
quite a while but the Minnesota Vikings
defense and the Green Bay Packers
defense very impressive in week one of
the Vikings they travel to Lambeau Field
their two and a half point underdogs are
you going to bet against my guy Aaron
Charles Rodgers you know I went back and
forth on this game a ton you guys here
is coach Zimmer who I absolutely love
he's my guy why because he prints money
58 in 23 and three against the spread as
a head coach on the flip side you got
cabbies guy Aaron Rodgers almost 80% win
percentage at Lambeau Field I am gonna
ride here with your guy and the Packers
play in two and a half ok-okay
divisional rivals nice so that that
those are our marquee matchups of the
week now it's time for the minds of the
public where Kelly will answer questions
from the be our audience before we get
to this how many times that people hit
you up on Twitter asking for your best
bet before the show started this weekend
was a good weekend so I got a lot of
deals but guys just wait and we'll give
you the goods yes at the end of the show
all right friends of Carla's wants to
know if sand Arnold is worth four points
to the spread how much our players like
Tom Brady and Patrick Malone's worth
this is actually a three-part question
now because Darnell is not really worth
four points the line move is more due to
the public perception the quarterback is
only worth what is back up his worth
it's a one-point drop-off in my math
Sam Darnell - Trevor Simeon who's Tom
Brady's backup I'm gonna admit this to
you guys I had to google it I was the
last time we saw Tom Brady back up like
four years ago with Jimmy G Jarrod
Stidham yes Tom Brady's working with
some eight points the betting line and
Patrick mahomes back up I knew he was
hurt so I had to google this one - Matt
Lohr the guys my age I couldn't tell you
the last time he played I think it was
for the Dolphins and what he would be
worth probably somewhere in the
double-digit range
she's Matt Morris 20 - yeah Matt Morris
20 - Thank You Cathy
shark sandwich ask I prefer to tease the
NFL can you give me your favorite teaser
this week I do love teasing the NFL but
let's take a step back here and explain
to those at home that don't know what a
teaser is it's a multi leg bet that
allows you to manipulate the spreads of
the game so for example I bet two team
six point teasers or minus 120 here at
Caesar's Palace
I love underdog so I'm going to tease
the Lions from two to eight and the
Giants from two to eight so that means
we're pumping through key numbers three
and seven three and seven or key numbers
because several games
in on that margin of victory more than
any other so that is my - team teaser
the Lions and the Giants last but not
least wide right says dolphins versus
Alabama on a neutral field what's the
spread and who you got yeah this is like
one of those questions that bookmakers
hate to answer I'm not a bookmaker so
I'm gonna answer for you but I need you
guys to stop with these insane
overreaction we're talking about a team
a college football team with less than
ten possible NFL players versus a team
with 53 NFL players but fun Soapy's you
guys at home and the producers in the
back Miami as bad as they played on
Sunday on a neutral field - thirty-six
and a half over Alabama and I would lay
that all day cabbie again imagine a
group of grown men losing a football
game to some college kids but it would
be Nick Saban versus his former NFL team
the Miami Dolphins so there we might see
all kinds of trick plays in order to get
some ports on the board
conversations over that's it minds of
the public this week guys make sure you
send in your questions into the VR app
or tag at VR underscore betting on
social we just heard from some of the
people at pole now I'm gonna check in
with the fans in the book
take it away cabbie Thank You Kelly you
know everybody's got a secret even you
guys at home and here at the B are
betting show we want to create a safe
space for athletes and celebrities to
reveal their biggest bad beats so this
week Clinton Portis sweats out an 11
team parlay with a possible payout of a
hundred grand
take a look I'm clean coordinates and
this is my bed in confession I took a
chance on a random day you know what I'm
putting this little bit of money to give
me an opportunity to win a lot let's see
how things go it was like 11 or 12 teams
that I'm looking at I'm like you know
what I like those team like I think all
of these teams are gonna win it
I never taken 11 team apart ladies but
hey you know what it was worth the
change
nine teams had actually covered now I'm
down to two teams my final two teams the
Houston Rockets in the sample daylight
Houston Rockets handle their business I
can't even focus on what I'm doing I
can't eat I can't drink I'm one game
away from $500,000 all know parlayed
that I didn't think I had a chance that
win it in the first place now it's up to
the devil daylight
zero zero the entire game they haven't
lost two games the entire season and
they're at home so I'm feeling hey you
know what this is money in the bag the
temple of enlightenment are definitely
gonna come through for me the game is
zero zero there's 46 seconds
why would you give up a gold goalie did
you not know I needed you
I'm telling you myself I needed you more
than I've ever needed anyone else did
you let me down you broke my heart it
still hurts to this day man as it should
which is the worst bad beat Porter says
parler loss or that same template Bay
Lightning's squad that finished first in
the regular season in points and then
got swept out of the first round I feel
for you Stamkos you two kucherov don't
forget to send us your betting
confessionals to add BR underscore
betting for a chance to be featured on
our social channels so let's check in
with the fans in the in the sports book
tell me what's happening out there
what's up cabby I'm getting ready to
give out my best bet if you followed me
last week you got an easy win with the
bangles plus nine and a half and coming
up I'm gonna share my favorite player
today before we get to my best bet I'm
gonna let these fans sell me on their
best bet whoever makes the most
convincing argument gets to tail me on
my bets I'm so excited it's now time for
convinced Kelly hi what's your name
where you from Detroit
Oh Sam from Detroit are you gonna tell
me about the Lions yes I am +12 half
stanford and the boys already played him
at plus two and a half you're late to
the party yeah I know but what I have is
fine they're gonna cover anyway I think
they're gonna win their game outright oh
yeah all day okay hang tight all right
next up hi what's your name Michael nice
to meet you Michael are you from
Pittsburgh Pennsylvania yep you have
agreement of Packers jersey on ru an
Aaron Rodgers fan I'm a bit bored thing
whoo that is a Brett Favre jersey come
on guys be better Kelly alright tell me
your favorite about today I like the
Pittsburgh Steelers and why we have a
rebound never read my last week we got
it handed to us and we'll be ready to
play - they're playing with the chip on
our shoulder absolutely okay am I gonna
see a big game from juju juju the game
from Jude you really disappointed me
last week no we will okay cool hang
tight I do like that Steelers better
last but not least hi what's your name
Jack from Tulsa
Oh Tulsa I do love Tulsa Homa tyler
lockett shoutout most definitely yes
all right yes you know I love this okay
tell me your favorite bet today the
favorite bed is the over in the Dallas
game with the Redskins the 46 okay
believe they're just gonna do it today
all right no defense hopeful
well reskins really doesn't have a
defense so we don't have to worry about
that Dallas do what you did last week
and we'll be good all right okay I got
some decisions to make here guys but I
think a roll with Jack from Tulsa
Oklahoma I do like I do like I do like
your bet I think we're gonna roll with
it we're gonna walk up to the window
after this and put some money on that
over thank you for hanging out here's
some BR swag for you thank you all right
guys if you want to roll with me stick
around for my best bet at the end of the
show back to you cabbie
thank you very much Kelly you know here
at bleacher report we operate by the
principle teamwork makes the dream work
so it's time for the peoples parlay the
fans at home will help me make this bet
we have $100 of BRS money on a
three-team parlay chosen by you and to
be frank we need to bounce back
everybody because last last week we
Rowan won and we only hit one of the
three legs which were the fort and the
San Francisco 49ers so it's time to
reveal our three teams this week we've
got Dee oh that's it we got the
Minnesota Vikings we're gonna bring them
all over we got the Minnesota Vikings
two plus two and a half
we got the New England Patriots who's
from Mike 19th from sorry - eighteen and
a half and we have the eidetic cider for
all this jewelry and we have the new
orleans saints which are plus one and a
half that is the people's parlay I hope
I look beautiful to you guys at home
Kelly what do you think yeah you do look
beautiful with all that bling but I
don't know about those teams looking
beautiful with me
you got a couple underdogs today which
I'm really happy about but and this is
my ticket Vicky dress parle look I don't
like any of those team what do you mean
you've got a couple underdogs you live
literally er that everybody gets to have
on social media yet nobody listens
that's okay so what is it what is your
best bet
all right guys the moment you've all
been waiting for it's time for my best
bet we got off to such a great start
last week week one cashing that bangle
almost outright winner plus nine and a
half we touched on divisional underdogs
earlier in the show and I'm sticking
with that theme saving my best my
favorite divisional underdog the
Redskins plus six yes social media I
know it another dog you guys love it I
really do believe Josh Norman's should
be able to neutralize Amari Cooper
Cowboys looked so great last week
against the Giants no doubt we have to
give them credit here but now they're
just hanging back and by the way they're
eight 21 and one against the spread
after beating the Giants the Redskins
keep this one close Kelly did you
somehow forget about one of the greatest
performances in the history of a Dallas
Cowboys quarterback in rain Dakota
Prescott who had 405 yards four
touchdowns Jason wouldn't even count one
of those touchdowns Amari Cooper
Michael gallop Ezekiel Ellie do you and
you're gonna bet against the Cowboys
listen too many points on the road a
divisional road game the Cowboys just
hang in tight watch this Scottie you're
gonna sit right here on the stage of
watch this game with the Redskins keep
it close shot our producer well biggest
Redskins standard I listen it's at Kelly
in Vegas on Twitter so Cowboys fans you
know where to light her up thank you for
joining us on the be our vetting show
presented by the Caesars Palace sports
book our journey continues on social add
VR underscore betting make sure to
follow along Chuck my pics and yours see
you guys next weekend we'll win this
parlay Kelly
[Applause]
[Music]